how do you start writing a comic book I
usually come up with a title first
but like this was last night I got a
email from a publisher friend of mine
who says he's starting up a new comic
and he has a color cover illustration
can I write a
story in five pages
based on that cover illustration
so then I gotta figure it out and figure
it and figure it out and there's certain
things he wants in that story I won't
say what they are because maybe
something else is wrong with the story
but certain story elements so I got to
figure out how to fit those story
elements into a five-page story that
includes the cover when I write these
stories for these magazines I regularly
write for now shutter and
vampirus carmilla
frequently the artist will get a hold of
a great cover painting that he wants to
use
and he calls me I was just can you write
a story
based on this cover
and sometimes the cover has a lot of
image
you know for instance there was recently
he sent me one with
a it was a headsman an executioner and
the hedgeman who was holding a certain
kind of ax
and a law he was standing like on a a a
a
pillar or a mountain the skull of human
skulls and there were a couple other
things money had a full moon or
something
and it had a title
and the title wasn't some generic title
that would fit
you know like curse of the Mummy will
fit anything and with a mummy in it
blood of the vampire will fit any
vampire story but this one is a specific
title
that couldn't be changed because he
needed a title for it to get in a
certain catalog that distributes the
magazines so I had to come up with a
story that came up with that executioner
that particular type of
um
weapon he was using to cut the heads off
all those skulls mine had a full moon
too if I can remember and that title
so I sleep on it and mull it over when
I'm walking around or
driving a car or watching TV or
something I keep mulling those things
around and sooner or later it comes
together and then it comes up with a a
last panel and the last panel in a
horror story
has to be a shock of some sort a
surprise if you're doing a superhero
story
ends in the end of if it's complete
story in itself you need an ending where
everything is resolved the bad guy is
caught or whatever you know but if it's
a continued story Into The Next Issue
then it needs some kind of a shock or
some kind of a surprise
all those things have to be taken into
account
but what to me that's easy because
that's where my strong points lay
what is the structure of a comic book
a structure well it's the first thing
you have to remember
is a comic book is visual
it can be a bunch of Talking Heads I
mean you can do it that way but people
are going to get bored with it it needs
to be visual it's pictures
and the panels there should be some kind
of a and not a lot of artists can't do
this a lot of artists can only do nice
like portraits and things
and Landscapes but telling a story from
one panel to the next continuity from
one channel to the next is the whole
talent in itself
and then the words
the captions the the dialogue
shouldn't repeat what you see in the
picture
you know I I make a joke I saw a um
a a
panel in a
science fiction comic book once
the picture showed a spaceship landing
on a planet
then there's a caption at the top of the
panel that said as the spaceship lands
on the planet dot dot
and then there's a dialogue balloon
coming out of the spaceship like
somebody in the spaceship talking we are
landing on the planet on our spaceship
you know Triple Threat redundancy there
if you're landing on the planet you
don't have to say they're landing on the
planet
and that's something
um a lot of writers
don't know or can't figure out
when when I was working for Russ Manning
on Tarzan
he said
and and I was making that mistake I was
being redundant in my family says no no
no that's not the way you do it and I
learned a lot from Russ as far as
writing comic books are concerned he
said
but he wanted the panels to be quote
dense with information unquote so when
you look at that panel you're seeing the
action but something in the panel tells
you something different
in addition to what you're seeing in the
action
or in the dialogue the dialogue will use
a word or two it's surprising when in a
how much information you can put in one
comic book panel just
if a character is doing something you
can see what that character is doing
something you don't have to say it in
the caption
or have the character say what what he
or she is doing
but in the character's expression or
body language you can say a lot more you
can you can
like they're doing this unwillingly
or they're being you know they're being
forced to do it or they're not taking it
seriously so you've already given a
second piece of information and if it's
let's say a scene
where there's mountains in the back
and the Sun is setting
and it has whatever the character is
doing something has something to do with
light
like it's a vampire trying to get to his
his coffin if you're uh as the sun's
Rising anyway you know that he's in a
hurry because any minute the sun's going
to come up and destroy him so and then
one panel he can three three bits of
information that are unrelated to each
other
and uh and that's the way I like to do
my stories do you use the same formula
for every comic book
I I'm doing the same format now for the
the ones I'm doing for shutter and
vampires carmilla because they have a
they have a house look and the way I
started the ones I submitted they were
accepted with no problems and the reason
was I just when I first started out I
said how do you want me to submit my
stories the Marvel style where you go
the artwork first or whatever he said
just write a script a full script and
that's what I do and and they've been
accepting everyone they've been fine
ever since
but if I was writing a I did a graphic
novel based on my movie Tales of
Frankenstein and I had
five artists working on it five
different artists and I ask each one how
do you want me to do it
with the exception of one all of them
wanted to do Marvel style
so what I did with them I wrote a
basic synopsis
I sent them this movie script
that was shot for the film
and then I sent him some photographs of
the actors playing those parts
and they did a beautiful job a wonderful
job how much description do you write
well if you're running with a running a
character that's well known
like I have with Tarzan Captain America
um the Vampirella or whoever the there's
the house look everybody knows what they
look like I don't have to describe them
at all
sometimes
um I'll go into great detail if it's a
if it's an unusual character a strange
Hunchback with one eye or a peg leg and
two colors hair or something you know
then I'll describe all the if it's a
special purpose at other times
um I'll just say let's get some
diversity in this story make some people
African-American make some Caucasian
make some Asian and let them just go
wild with it if there's certain kind of
clothes you know like those uh
uh a sexy young woman I'll say
everywhere's you know like a mini skirt
or shorts or a halter top or you know
something like that or if it's a western
story I do a lot of westerns that are
horror stories I'll say um
you know make sure that the guns don't
look like a Hollywood gun or sometimes
they make sure they do look like a
Hollywood gun belt or in some cases I've
used historical fig I love using
historical characters I mean Jesse James
Frank Nitty Wild Bill Hickok from Wyatt
Earp and I'll say look up online you'll
see photos of the way they were the way
they looked
so sometimes the description is very
precise sometimes it's very general
and sometimes it's non-existent really
how do you keep the reader turning the
page
that's a great question and a lot of
writers and artists don't know this
either and again I learned this from
Russ Manning
and when an artist changes the
arrangement of my panels I go I go
berserk because they're pages are
designed to make you turn the page
the last panel on every right hand page
and we open the book up and you have a
right hand page on the left hand page
the right hand page the last panel
should either be something surprising a
shock
or a scene a total scene change so the
whole page is about somebody out in the
forest the last panel is a castle
and then you go to your Castle scene
that makes them want to see what's on
the next page or
it's a the guy walking through the
forest and the last page is
what is he terrified about you turn the
page it's a werewolf attacking them
lunging for him or it's simply a
some somebody like in the story I just
wrote finished today
somebody's being stalked and the last
panel is I'm getting clubbed up close up
clubbed over there they don't know
they're being socked
last band was a close-up clubbed over
the head from behind with a beer bottle
and knocked out cold those are the ways
you and the page
so it all has to fall on the right page
yes or it should ideally but a lot of
people don't do that they don't know
that
how do you write Cliffhangers
a cliff of air is just
in my younger years and when I was a kid
I saw a lot of old movie cereals
where at the end of the everyone was
like like 12 or 15 chapters long and at
the end of the chapter the car goes off
the cliff
or a building they get trapped in a
building the building explodes
and I wrote novels that way using those
types of Cliffhangers of course they got
to figure out how to get you you're
going to get your hero out of those
situations
and there was an old story that there
was a a writer who wrote pulse magazines
who was a notorious drunk
and he would write the stories and then
they would but he was always did the job
and there was this one thing where the
hero got caught in quicksand it was
thinking in the quicksand
and these books are these magazines were
published like I know a weekly or a
weekly basis and they're getting close
to the deadline and they didn't have an
ending they didn't know how the next
story was going to begin and how he's
going to get out of the
quicksand
so the the writer finally showed up and
he was drunk out of his mind and he
walked staggers into the office and he
sits down behind a typewriter puts a
piece of paper and cranks it up
he starts typing and these types the
whole chapter out and then he walks out
of the room walks out of the office so
they went and they grabbed the story out
of there
because they're going to go to the
printer and just started off with him
saying
after Buck got out of the quicksand
and then he went into the rest of the
story so he never told you how he got
out of it and I don't know if that's a
true story but it's a famous
a story that's been going around for
decades with pulp writers and I consider
myself in many ways a pulp writer
but I um I did a story once with the
hero
got locked in a safe
at the end of the chapter the next chat
oh then then the the crooks come up to
the safe who know the combination they
open up the safe and they've
shoot machine guns into the safe
that's how it ended
I had to figure out a way of getting him
out of the safe and there's the old
cliche line well safe
it's a Secret Safe from meant to be
broken
not to be broken into not to be
so you couldn't break into them but not
break out of them but that wasn't good
enough
so I have a friend in New Jersey who
used to be an escape artist
and I called him up I got his his
voicemail and I said I'm not asking you
to give me away any Trade Secrets
but I got my hero locked in a safe
how am I going to get him out of it so
he doesn't get machine gun
the day went by and then at 2 A.M he's a
real night owl and especially when you
think
it's three years later in New Jersey
I get this I was screening my calls and
I get this voice laughing his head off
he couldn't control himself
any I finally I knew what it was when I
picked up the phone and he said nobody
here has ever asked me this question
get a pencil and this is how you do it
and in the story
I had the hero getting out of the safe
he was using he said what brand is it
what my you know and we figured we
worked all that out so I ended up
dedicating the novel to him
and I said to Jim sterenko who told me
how to get my hero out of the safe and
and that's uh that's the way how I how I
worked out of out that Cliffhanger
usually I use the
in prose fiction
I use the standard ways they got out of
them in the old movie cereals jump out
of the car at the last moment you know
jump out of the
window the building before just seconds
before it blows up and that kind of
thing
but but the safe one was really was
really something
sorry just one last thing um what is a
pulp writer can you define that oh a
pulp writer was a writer who wrote for
the old it had a little different
meaning now but originally had
um was a writer who wrote for the fall
magazines
usually very fast very cheaply he got
paid maybe a penny or a half a cent of
word
or maybe a quarter percent a word and he
knocked these things out
they were usually very Lura they had
very lured coverage they had titles like
weird Tales
black mask magazines startling Terror I
mean things that comic books use years
later
and the stories were always really
improbable but you know Tarzan and Fu
Manchu they all got their start in the
pope magazines in later years the pope
writers turned basically to paperbacks
and they wrote some of the early science
fiction stories and but also things like
Doc Savage
the spider the Shadow and I've written a
lot of Frankenstein novels The New
Adventures of Frankenstein I wrote 12 of
them and they're always with a lot of
action a lot of mad scientists and
pretty heroines and
sadistic fiends and mad doctors and
monsters
and um so I consider myself a pulp
writer in fact I did one recent in the
last few years about a basically a mass
character who put a mask on it called
jawbreaker and he gets his name because
he hits a crook and he says he broke my
jaw hey that's a good name for myself
that's where that name come from but he
got into all the old kind of
fights and chases and Cliffhangers
how many written pages is a comic book
well comic books can be any length
in the old days most of the the filler
stories like an Action Comics you would
have action Superman would have the long
story and then in the back it would be
zotara the magician and Congo Bill it
was sort of like jungle gym and
vigilante who's a western character and
they were usually about five pages long
um then they been expanded to like when
I think when I was working a lot of
writing a lot of stories from Marvel I
think the stories were maybe 17 pages
long when I worked at gold key the
full-length books were 25 pages long but
the filler stories were 10 pages long
the stories I'm writing now generally
are the ones for
shutter and vampires carmilla magazines
and those even though some of the other
artists writers write them
in five pages I write them in six pages
I found out with my own writing
experience that six pages is ideal for
telling a short horror story and has a
surprise ending the ones I was doing for
gold key were the 10 pages and thinking
back now I think they were probably a
little bit longer than they needed to be
and I have a little bit of difficulty
cramming everything in the five pages
even though I've done it for the same
company because the artist only wanted
was available for five pages but then we
have what they call graphic novels
there can be 60 some pages long and all
done by the same writer and the same
artist telling one long story I've done
some of those too and
um
but I'm real comfortable now
and have a really good time writing
these six page horror stories
can you clarify what you mean by Pages
Yeah by a page I mean a printed page
what you see on the page when you buy
the magazine
[Music]
um
so
one comic book page of script
might be half a page long or it might be
two pages long it really just depends
what
you're trying to say how much you have
to describe and
sometimes you have a page with no
dialogue for trying to make some kind of
a dramatic point
so it has more impact if you just show
the artwork or maybe a sound effect
you're there and you can do that and
a quarter of a page you know
panel one
long wide shot of Heroes fighting panel
two tighter shot panel three close-up
fist hitting face
you can do that in a page or less
how long does it take you to write a
comic book
the ones I'm writing now the six pages
it takes me about three to four hours to
do the first draft
which then I tinker with
well in the evening any word changing a
word here and there the next day I do a
rewrite that usually takes me about
two hours maximum then I let that sit
and then I sleep on it and if I come up
with any ideas in the morning sometimes
I come up with a major idea but usually
it's just a word here and there or
adding another panel or taking the panel
out something like that
so it's really a you might say it's a
three-day process for a six-page story
but most of the time I'm doing something
else
and it's very little time is actually
spent writing
so is it usually you come up with the
title first or the cover art is giving I
usually with these horror stories I've
been doing it's either one or the other
usually there have been times where I've
come up with an idea of
hey let's use Jesse James in a sorry
and I don't know what the story is going
to be here what the title is going to be
or anything I just know
I've got to do some research on Jesse
James and then I find out all these
things about his life and career hey
this will work in right this will fit
right in like I opened up the Billy the
kids I mean the Wild Bill Hickok story
with him getting assassinated the first
panel that got three panels at the top
this hasn't been published yet three
panels at the top of him and Dodge and
deadwoods in the town of Deadwood saying
goodbye to
Calamity Jane his girlfriend and I gotta
meet I gotta go to this poker game which
be careful she says you know remember
your eyesight's starting to fail I know
and so the Big Splash panel which is
that big panel you always see on the
first page
it's still a big take off from the back
sitting there and Jack McCall was ready
to fire the clip you know pulling the
hammer back ready to shoot
him in the back of the head with with
the dead man's hand he's holding that's
the way it opened and then that went to
uh him being Zapped Away by aliens
called Ali
Angels um Aces and Aliens as opposed to
Aces and they Aces and eights so I I
thought of that scene of Wild Bill
Hickok then I had to do some research on
Wild Bill of Hickok
I did one with Frank Nitty the other day
and it's already out I think it might be
in the current issue where Frank ninney
is being stalked by a vampire that he
inadvertently caused created and he
calls up Elliot Ness his main enemy
with The Untouchables to help him get
out of this jam and not only in this
who can't stand for agnity is no longer
in the Untouchable he's already getting
ready to leave for
Pennsylvania wherever he went and um
I had to research all the stuff about
Frank ninney all I knew was what I saw
on the TV shows and in the movie
and uh but I love doing that research I
love the stories where I can put in a
historical character that I had to do
something looking up on and those are
what I get the most pleasure out of the
most satisfaction but all in six pages